e não vai ser preciso eu falar muito
para que alguns de vocês começa a pensar
esse cara deve ser gay
E durante boa parte da minha vida
conviver com esse medo e com receio do
que as pessoas pensavam ao meu respeito
sempre foi o meu maior pesadelo Afinal
desde muito pequeno isso sempre foi uma
questão
e quando eu era criança eu gostava de
desenhar de brincar de boneca de dançar
com as minhas amigas e como uma criança
que rebolava eu era taxado de gay
e durante a adolescência por mais que lá
dentro eu tivesse uma vontade enorme de
viver para ser o medo do preconceito da
repressão e obrigou a ser para viver
e eu tinha vergonha de responder quando
o professor me perguntava de sair para
festas porque sempre isso vinha
acompanhado de algum comentário maldoso
de alguma risada no fundo da sala e de
uma pergunta que sempre foi o meu maior
Carmo Por que você é tão
é engraçado para não dizer outra coisa
que ser gay o ser estava muito
mais na cabeça do outro do que na minha
própria Parecia um anciosos para que eu
respondesse Sim eu sou mas eu também
tinha dúvidas Eu também procurava
entender se aquilo que eu sentia tinha
nome se era certo errado fora em
inúmeras outras perguntas que não
conseguiu ser respondidas com a ajuda
dos meus pais das minhas escolas e dos
meus amigos nenhum deles tinha recebido
a preparação suficiente para me ajudar
se pelo contrário o que eles ouviram ao
longo da vida estava relacionado com a
ideia de perversão de um desvio que
precisava ser corrigido
e quantas vezes eu não ouvi para
engrossar a voz para rebolar menos para
ser menos afeminado mas hoje eu não
culpo essas pessoas por isso eu
claramente vejo que elas não foram
Preparadas
eu entro medo de estar fazendo algo
errado e de machucar aqueles que eu
amava eu crescer de forma solitário
e quando eu era criança eu construir um
mundo de fantasias e ao mesmo tempo onde
eu podia ser quem eu realmente queria
ser na sala da minha casa tem que os
meus pais os meus vizinhos pudessem ver
e na adolescência encontrei muitas
respostas por meio de amigos virtuais
que muitas vezes tinham mais empatia e
sensibilidade do que aquelas pessoas que
estavam ao meu lado
Ah e por meio do virtual eu descobri que
tinha mais gente com as mesmas dores os
mesmos medos os mesmos receios que eu
o que essas pessoas faziam parte de um
grupo a comunidade LGBT que ia mais
sigla para falar dos gays lésbicas
pessoas trans intersexuais pansexuais a
gêneros e aliados
é bom se a gente é do mesmo grupo eu
posso dizer que a gente ia no mesmo
barco certo e se a gente tá no mesmo
barco com certeza a gente vai te ajudar
certo errado as pessoas LGBT que ia mais
não são só vítimas de preconceito por
parte de quem não é LGBT muita gente não
sabe mas essas pessoas também são
discriminadas por outras da própria
comunidade o que na teoria deveria ser o
principal ponto de entendimento de
acolhimento de empatia
e por exemplo falando de mim um homem
gay se você não fala Grosso se você não
é másculo você é uma poc o mesmo
que pão com ovo a Femme nada afetada de
voz fina tudo bem a gente tem caminhada
por mais respeito em direção a esse
perfil mas sempre ele foi a principal
representação caricata e estereotipada
dos gays em teatros e programas de
televisão
é mas a poc não é a única ser
discriminada se você está acima do peso
pessoas trans negras uma mulher pouco
feminina acabam sendo vítimas de
preconceito e discriminação pela própria
comunidade
Tô voltando para minha história e
fazendo um link com esse ponto quando eu
encontrei o meu grupo quando eu
encontrei a comunidade Aquele momento
que deveria ser um momento de paz de
alívio se tornou uma prisão
e eu precisei me esconder por anos e eu
não podia ser quem eu realmente queria
ser
e para que eu pudesse ficar com quem eu
queria ficar para que eu pudesse ser
aceito eu tive que me esconder
é mas eu também não curto essas pessoas
por isso elas também não foram
Preparadas
e por isso quando eu fui para uma
empresa que não só tinha diversidade e
inclusão como um princípio mas projetos
de impacto para uma comunidade da qual
eu faço parte eu decidi que eu iria
aproveitar do meu lugar de fala para que
a história de ninguém passasse por isso
é porque toda vez que acontece é a
história de alguém que estamos colocando
em jogo e hoje quando eu compartilho a
minha história com vocês eu faço como um
grito de alívio de algo que ficou
guardado por anos e que foi transformado
em força e esperança para puxar uma
parcela bem pequena dessa mudança
de dentro da Uber ontem oportunidade de
liderar mais de 300 voluntários focados
na inclusão LGBT que ia mais na América
Latina é um grupo carinhosamente pensado
a partir das necessidades e das
carências dessa comunidade e Dos
objetivos de negócio da Uber tendo a
educação como Pilar como elemento comum
para os nossos três pilares de atuação
o que eu fiz nossos escritórios tenham
mais representatividade em especial das
pessoas trans além de recrutamento e
seleção a gente realiza capacitações
periódicas sobre viessem consciente por
fim para aqueles lgbts em situação de
vulnerabilidade a gente realiza
capacitações presenciais e virtuais
sobre educação financeira e
empreendedorismo e empoderamento o
pessoal porque acreditar em si próprio é
o primeiro passo para uma grande mudança
as coisas meus exemplos eu vou chegando
ao final a educação ela não tem que
ensinar só para o trabalho a educação
ela precisa ensinar para a vida
nós precisamos falar sim sobre
identidade de gênero e orientação sexual
desde que nos entendemos por gente
precisamos falar sobre mais respeito
mais inclusão e representatividade em
todos os nossos círculos sociais seja na
mesa de jantar no almoço de domingo na
sala da Universidade ou da escola
infantil com os amigos da comunidade o
até com aqueles que estão fora dela
e enquanto a gente não se preparar para
isso a gente vai continuar impedindo com
que diversos Pedros fernandas Phillips
Luciana seanas explorem todo seu
potencial e possam ser que realmente
desejam ser sim pessoas felizes produzem
mais porque não têm medo de serem
repreendidos E você meu amigo pode ter
uma parcela de culpa ou de Glória nessas
coisas do outro de que lado você quer
estar
e a mudança só acontece com conhecimento
e eu conhecimento exige profundidade
repetição e acima de tudo empatia
reconhecendo que mesmo diferentes somos
feitos do mesmo tecido
e eu não culpo quem me chamou de
que me pediu para engrossar a
voz para rebolar ou a terminar menos eu
espero do fundo do meu coração que essas
pessoas possam parar refletir e dar o
primeiro passo
eu nunca é tarde para começar da mesma
forma que nunca é tarde para que você
seja sua versão mais verdadeira
autêntica e feliz muito obrigado